[Music]
hey friends welcome to another episode
of machine learning experts i'm your
host brittany muller and today's guest
is none other than louis tunstall
lewis is a machine learning engineer at
hugging face where he works on applying
transformers to automate business
processes and ml ops challenges
lewis has built machine learning
applications for startups and
enterprises in the domains of nlp
topological data analysis and time
series
you're going to hear lewis talk about
his new book i actually have it right
here
ahsoka
uh his new book transformers large-scale
model evaluation and how he's working to
help machine learning engineers optimize
for faster latency and higher throughput
and more
in a previous life lewis was a
theoretical physicist and outside of
work he loves to play guitar go trail
running and contribute to open source
projects
if you want to learn more about how
hugging face experts like lewis can help
accelerate your machine learning roadmap
please go to hf dot co
support to learn more
so excited to introduce this really fun
and brilliant episode to you
here is my conversation with louis
tunstall
thank you so much for taking time out of
your busy schedule to chat with me today
about some of your awesome work
thanks brittany it's a pleasure to be
here
awesome i'm curious if you could just do
a brief self introduction
and highlight
you know what brought you to hugging
face in the first place
yeah it's a great question so
i would say what brought me to hugging
face was really transformers um so
i think it was like 2018 or so i was
working with transformers at a startup
in switzerland
and my first project um was like a
question answering task where you have a
bit of text and you're just trying to
find
the answer in that text
and in those days the library was
actually called pytorch pre-trained vert
and it was
it was like a very you know focused code
base
with a couple of scripts
but for me like it was the first time i
had ever
worked with transformers and i had
really no idea like what was going on so
i read the paper the original attention
is all you need paper i couldn't
understand it
and so i then
you know started looking around for some
resources to learn from
and in the process hugging face really
exploded with the library growing into
many more architectures
and i got really excited about this idea
of contributing to open source software
and so
around 2019 i had this like kind of
crazy idea to write a book
about transformers because i felt there
was this gap
that was missing
and i kind of
partnered up with a friend called
leandra and we sent tom a cold email out
of nowhere saying hey we're going to
write a book about transformers are you
interested
and i was expecting like no response um
and then to our great surprise he said
yeah sure let's have a chat
and around one and a half years later
yeah
and so this this collaboration i think
set the seeds for
for us eventually um joining hugging
face and
i've been here now for around nine
months
that is incredible how does it feel to
have a copy of your book
in your hands
i have to say like because i just became
a parent about a year and a half ago and
it feels kind of similar to my son being
born
oh my god i love that you know
you're holding this like thing that you
created um and you know it's it's quite
uh an exciting feeling and
it's such a different thing to actually
hold it compared to you know reading a
pdf
yeah
seeing it it's actually real
um you know that you didn't just dream
about it for the last uh yeah
exactly that is incredible
congratulations i want to briefly uh
read one endorsement that i just love in
this book and this is obviously not like
an endorsement of you know this isn't a
paid ad we just absolutely adore louis
and we're so proud of the work that you
put in to make this book happen and i
just love love love
this um this is one of the praises for
natural language processing with
transformers
by luca i'm probably saying this wrong
perozi phd data science machine learning
associate manager at accenture
he says complexity made simple this is a
rare and precious book about nlp
transformers and the growing ecosystem
around them hugging face whether there
are still buzzwords to you or are
already you already have a solid grasp
of it all the authors will navigate you
with humor scientific rigor and plenty
of code examples into the deepest
secrets of the coolest technology around
from off-the-shelf pre-trained to from
scratch custom models and from
performance to missing labels issues the
authors address practically every real
life struggle of a ml engineer and
provides state-of-the-art solutions
making this book destined to dedicate
this
to dictate the standards in the field
for years to come
i love that one
curious if we can get a little bit more
context to the work that you've done
with the transformers library and
you know sort of
everything that's
happened from you coming across
attention is all you need to
today
yeah sure so
one of the things that um i experienced
in my previous job before hugging face
was there's this kind of challenge in
industry when you want to deploy these
models into production
and the most common reason
is really because these models are
really large in terms of the number of
parameters and this adds a lot of kind
of complexity
for your requirements you may have so
for example if you're trying to build a
chatbot you need this
model to be very fast and responsive
and most of the time these models
are a bit too slow if you just take you
know the off-the-shelf model you train
it and you try to then integrate it into
your application
so what i've been working on for the
last few months on the transformers
library is providing the functionality
to export these models into a format
that lets you
run this much more efficiently
using you know tools that we have a
hugging face but also just general tools
in the open source ecosystem
in a way the philosophy of the
transformers library
is kind of like writing lots of code so
that the you know users don't have to
write that code right and
in this particular example what we're
talking about is something called the
open x format it's a special format that
um is used in industry
where you can basically have a model
that's written in pi torch but you can
then convert it to tensorflow or you can
run it on some very you know dedicated
hardware
and if you actually look at what's
needed to make this kind of conversion
happen in the transformers library it's
fairly gnarly
but we make it so that you only really
have to run one line of code and you
know the library will take care of it
for you and so the idea is that then
this particular feature lets
machine learning engineers or even data
scientists
in industry
take their model
convert it to this format and then
optimize it
to get faster latency
and higher throughput
wow that's very cool have there been um
any standout applications
of
transformers that are some of your
favorites or that you could speak to a
little bit
yeah so i think there's a few one that
one is
maybe like emotional or personal so yeah
for example i think for many many of us
um when openi released gpt2
this is a very famous language model
which um can generate text
and i remember like leandra and i were
working together at the same startup at
this time and
openly i released this model and they
actually provided in their blog post
some examples of the kind of essays that
this model had created
and one of them was like really funny it
was like
should um
you know write an essay about like why
we shouldn't recycle or why recycling is
bad for the world
and the model wrote this like very like
compelling essay why recycling was bad
and you know i printed it out and i
stuck it right above like our recycling
bin that we had
um as a kind of joke and and people were
like going uh well you know who wrote
this
i think there's something kind of like
sort of strangely human right where if
we see
generated text we we kind of get more
surprised by that when it kind of looks
like something that you know i would
have written
um
versus you know the many more
applications that have been happening
much more around you know classifying
text or
you know more conventional tasks
yeah that's incredible i remember when
they released those examples for gpt2
and one of my favorites i thought was so
funny and it almost gave me this sense
of oh we're not quite there yet but were
some of the more like inaccurate
mentions of i remember they had in some
of the articles they provided like
underground or underwater fires
and i remember thinking like how clever
and funny and interesting but how like
at the time seemed so impossible and
then something had happened with an oil
spill that next year where there was
actually fires underwater and i remember
immediately thinking about
that text and thinking oh maybe ai's
onto something already that we're not
quite aware of but
that is pretty pretty incredible
seems like yourself and other leading
experts at hugging face have been
working really hard to provide course
material and educational resources
curious how that came about and um what
you're currently working on there
yeah yeah great thanks that's a great
question so um but when i joined hugging
face um sylvan and lisandra they're the
core maintainers of the transformers
library
um they were developing a course um to
basically bridge the gap
um between people who are kind of maybe
more like say software engineers who are
kind of curious about natural language
processing
but specifically curious about
the transformers kind of revolution
that's been happening
and so i worked with them and others in
the open source team to create a free
course um called the hugging face course
and this course is designed to really
help people go from knowing you know
kind of not so much about nlp all the
way through to
you know having a kind of ability to
train models on many different tasks
and we've released like two parts of
this course and we're planning to
release the third part this year
and i'm really excited about
this like next part that we're
developing right now where we're going
to um explore like different modalities
where transformers are really powerful
so
you know most of the time we think of
transformers for nlp
but
lately there's kind of been this
explosion where transformers are now
being used in things like audio or in
computer vision
and we're going to be looking at these
in detail
in the next part that is so exciting i'm
curious um
what are some applications
that you're excited about
seeing
some of those models
kind of play into in the future
yeah so one that's kind of fun is um in
the course we had an event um last year
where we
basically got people in the community to
use the course material to build
applications
and um one of the participants in this
event they created um a cover letter
generator for for jobs so the idea is
that you know when you apply for a job
there's always this annoying thing like
you have to write a cover letter and
it's always like a bit like there like
you know you have to be witty yeah so
this guy created a
cover letter generator where you provide
some information about i guess yourself
and then it generates it from that
and he actually used that to apply to
hugging phase
no way yeah he's joining the science
team
as an intern um soon so
i mean this is like a super cool way
right like yeah
and you use that thing to apply um which
i thought was pretty awesome
where do you
want to see
more applications
yeah that's a great question
so i think personally
the the area that i'm like most excited
about is the application of machine
learning to like natural sciences um
and that's partly because of my
background i used to be a physicist in a
previous lifetime
um but i think what's also very exciting
here is
um
in a lot of like fields for example in
physics or in chemistry
you you already know what the say
underlying laws are
in terms of equations that you can write
down
but it turns out that many of the
problems that you're interested in
studying they often require simulation
um or they often require like very
hardcore super computers to kind of
understand and solve these equations
right and one of the most exciting
things to me is the kind of combination
of like deep learning
um with like you know the prior
knowledge that scientists have gathered
to kind of make breakthroughs that
weren't previously possible and i think
here a great example is like deepmind's
um
alpha fold model for like
protein structure prediction
where they were basically using like a
combination of like transformers with
some you know extra information
to generate predictions of proteins
that i think previously were taking on
the order of months and now they can do
them in kind of days and so this kind of
accelerates the whole field in a really
powerful way
and
i can imagine you know these
applications ultimately lead to
hopefully a better future for the
humanity
absolutely
wow that is super interesting it's funny
too listening to some podcasts that
thomas wolfe has done he's mentioned
that as well part of his you know
physics background
he thinks about things just as you
mentioned in terms of what's possible
with you know leveraging machine
learning
in ways that you know if you were to do
a
in a real life environment would be next
to impossible to scale
exactly super interesting wow very very
cool
uh so kind of shifting a little bit into
the world of model evaluation i think
this is a super interesting topic
especially because
you know you often hear
black box with
machine learning all the time or you
know even papers being released without
any
uh data sets or models you know
information so i think it's
a fascinating space to you know explore
and i'm really curious to get your take
on you know the work that you're doing
and how you see the world of model
evaluation evolving
yeah that's a great question so at
hugging face one of the things i've been
working on has been
trying to kind of build the
infrastructure and the tooling that
enables what we call like large scale
evaluation so
you may know that the huge face hub has
thousands of models and data sets
but if you're kind of trying to navigate
this space you might ask yourself okay
um i'm interested in say question
answering um i want to know what is like
the top say 10 models on on this
particular task yeah and at the moment
it's kind of hard to to find the answer
to that not just on the hub but in
general in the space of machine learning
it's quite hard you you often have to
read papers and then you have to kind of
take those models and just test them
yourself manually and that's very kind
of slow and inefficient
so one thing that we've been working on
is to develop a way that
you can evaluate models and data models
on data sets directly through the hub
and
yeah we're sort of still trying to
experiment there in that direction um
but i'm hoping that we have something
cool to show this year
um and there's another side to this
which is that
um a large part of like measuring
progress in machine learning is through
the use of benchmarks
and
these benchmarks are traditionally
a set of data sets
with some tasks
and
what's kind of been maybe missing is
that a lot of researchers they they
speak to us and say hey i've got this
cool idea for a benchmark but i don't
really want to implement all of the you
know nitty-gritty
like infrastructure for the submissions
and the maintenance and those things and
so
we've been working with some really cool
partners um on hosting benchmarks on the
hub directly
so that then you know people in the
research community can kind of use the
the tooling that we have and then
simplify the kind of evaluation of these
models
oh
that is super interesting and powerful
yeah maybe one thing to mention is that
um
the the whole like
kind of question of evaluation is is a
very subtle one because
for example we know from
like previous benchmarks
that most of the time when we design a
task for example
there's a very famous one called squad
which tries to measure how good models
are at question answering well that's
the aim
but it turns out that
many of these like transform models are
really good at taking shortcuts
so
if
what they're what they're actually doing
is like they're kind of getting a very
high score on a benchmark but that
doesn't necessarily translate into the
actual thing that you were interested in
which was like answering questions and
you have all these kind of subtle
failure modes where the models will you
know
maybe provide completely wrong answers
or they they should not even answer at
all this kind of thing
and so at the moment in the research
community there's a very kind of active
and vigorous discussion
about kind of what role benchmarks
play in in the way we measure progress
but also you know how these benchmarks
kind of encode our values as a community
and one thing that i think hugging face
um can can really offer the the
community here is the means to kind of
um diversify the the sort of space of
values because you know traditionally
most of these research papers come from
the us which is you know a great country
i mean you're from the united
states it's a small slice of the kind of
human experience right
yeah
i do want to ask what
you've seen as a common mistake
uh in machine learning maybe this is
across you know more experienced machine
learning engineers or teams are there
any
common
like missteps or
things that are overlooked
yeah i can maybe tell you the ones that
i've done yeah that's perfect probably
you know
a good representative of the rest of the
um things so
i i think the the biggest lesson i
learned when i was starting out in the
field is um
not using a baseline model um when
you're when you're really starting out
so
a common problem that i did and i then
later saw other kind of junior engineers
doing is you really reach for like the
most fancy state-of-the-art model
and
although that may work
a lot of the time what happens is you
introduce a lot of complexity into the
problem and your state-of-the-art model
may have a bug and you won't really know
because the model's so complex
and so a really common pattern
especially in industry and especially
with nlp
is that you can get pretty far with
something called regular expressions and
with like linear models like logistic
regression and i mean these kind of
things will
really give you a good start and then
and then if you can build a better model
then great you should do that but it's
great to have a reference point
um and then i think the second like big
lesson i learned from building a lot of
projects
is that um
you you can get a bit obsessed with like
the modeling part of the problem because
that's kind of the exciting bit when
you're doing machine learning but
there's like this whole like you know
like ecosystem especially if you work in
a large company there will be this whole
ecosystem of services and things that
are around your application
and so kind of the lesson there is like
you should really try to build something
like end to end that maybe doesn't even
have any machine learning at all um but
it's kind of the scaffolding upon which
you can um you know
build the rest of the system because you
can spend all this time training an
awesome model and then you go oh oops it
doesn't you know integrate with like you
know the requirements we have in our
application and then you've wasted all
this time
right
that's a good one the don't over
engineer
is something i always try to keep in
mind
exactly and it's just it's just like a
natural thing i think as humans we
especially if you're like dirty you
really want to
find the most like kind of interesting
way to do something and you know most of
the time simple is better
totally
i love that
that's so good to keep in mind uh if you
could go back and do one thing
differently at the beginning of your
career in machine learning what would it
be
oh wow that's a tough one
hmm
oh i actually don't know the answer to
that just give me you might have to cut
this out again
no you're take your time you're good um
one thing different
so the reason why this is a really hard
question to answer is because
um i'm you know now working at hugging
face and it's like the most kind of
fulfilling um type of work that i've
i've really done in my whole life
and the question is like you know if i
changed something when i started out
maybe i wouldn't be here right
so
it's one of those things where it's a
tricky one in that sense yeah but um
i suppose one thing that maybe i would
have done slightly differently is um
when i started out i started out working
in
as a data scientist
and
as a data scientist you tend to kind of
um develop the skills which are about
like kind of mapping business problems
to
um software problems or ultimately
machine learning problems
and this is like a kind of really great
skill to have but what i later
discovered is that my like kind of true
driving passion is like doing open
source software development
and so probably the thing i would have
done differently would have been to kind
of you know really start that much
earlier
you know because at the end of the day
most of open source is really driven by
kind of community
members and so
this would have been maybe a way to
shortcut you know my path to doing this
full-time
i love that
i love the idea of yeah if you had done
something differently maybe you wouldn't
be a hugging face so
it's like the butterfly effect movie
right you go back in time and then you
know you don't have any legs or
something
totally totally
uh don't want to mess with a good thing
you know
that's so good
uh all right fun rapid fire question
sony's get so weird so bear with us but
this is gonna be really fun i'm excited
to hear your answers
um
all right so just first thing that comes
to mind um and we'll just kind of rifle
through these
so best piece of advice for someone
looking to get into ai machine learning
um just start
yeah i like that just just start coding
just uh
contributing if you want to do open
source just start
you can always find reasons not to do it
and yeah
you just have to get your hands dirty
i love that
uh what are some of the
industries you're most excited to see
machine learning applied
as i mentioned before i think in the
natural sciences this is where i think
that's like most exciting um if we if we
look at something say at the industrial
side
i guess some of the development of like
drugs like new drugs through machine
learning it's very exciting
um and i guess also i can imagine like
personally i'd be really happy if there
was advancements in robotics where i
could finally have a robot to like fold
my laundry because
i really hate doing this and it would be
nice if like there was an automated way
of handling that totally i love that
that's great
uh should people be afraid of ai taking
over the world
maybe
or
um
it's a tough one because i think we have
reasons to think that um
we may create
systems that are
quite um dangerous in the sense that
they could be used to cause a lot of
harm and this is i think an analogy is
perhaps with you know weapons like you
can use weapons the sport but you can
also use them for you know war
um and
i would say that one big risk is
probably if we think about you know
combining these techniques with the
military perhaps this this
leads to some tricky situations
um but yeah i i think right now i'm not
super worried about like
the terminator i'm more worried
about i don't know a rogue agent on the
financial stock market and you know
bankrupting the whole world
yeah
that's a good point sorry that that's a
bit dark no i like that i like that
perspective a lot that's great
the correct answer no this is great this
is a kind of a follow-up on your folding
laundry robot but when will ai assisted
robots be in homes everywhere
honest answer i don't know
um
everyone i do know who's working on
robotics says this is
still like an extremely difficult task
um in the sense that robotics hasn't
quite experienced the same kind of
revolutions that
like nlp and you know deep learning more
generally have had
um but on the other hand you can see
some pretty exciting developments um
kind of in the last year especially
around the idea of being able to kind of
transfer
knowledge from simulation into the real
world and
i don't know i think there's hope that
in my lifetime i will have a yeah
i hope so too i know it's something i
believe lex friedman's been working on
the in-home robotics
yeah i think he's also very interested
in like the human robot interaction with
autonomous vehicles
yeah it's very cool it's fascinating
space yeah hopefully within our lifetime
we'll get some
laundry assisted robotics what have you
been interested in lately it could be a
movie a recipe a podcast literally
anything
and i'm just curious what that is and
how someone interested in that might
find it or get started
yeah it's great question so
for me it's like podcasts in general are
like my uh kind of
new way of reading books because a lot
of the time you know i have a young baby
and so i'm just kind of like doing
chores and listening at the same time
and um one podcast that really stands
out recently is actually the deepmind
podcast
so
this um this is a podcast that's um
produced by hannah frye who's a
mathematician in the uk
and she gives this like beautiful
journey through like not just what
deepmind does but more generally
what deep learning and especially
reinforcement learning
how they're impacting you know the world
and listening to this podcast it gives
you this because you know the english
have such great accents yeah like it
feels like you're listening to like a
bbc documentary and
you feel like really inspired because a
lot of the work that you know she
discusses in in this podcast it has
strong overlap with what we do at
hugging face and so you kind of see that
there's like this you know much bigger
picture of
trying to pave the way for a better
future and
it um quite it resonated strongly and
i just love it because the explanations
are just super
clear and you can share it with like you
know your family and your friends and
say hey if you want to know what i'm
kind of doing this gives you a kind of
rough idea
oh i love that it's called deep mind
just the best
yeah
it gives you a very interesting insight
into the deep mind like you know
researchers and you know yeah kind of
the backstory as well which is quite
cool
oh my gosh that's incredible i'm
definitely going to give that a listen i
love finding podcasts like that it
reminds me just how you explained it a
little bit data skeptic
uh he distills
data science topics and theories and
mathematics in really easy to consume
ways
um
very cool i love finding little gems
like that
good share thank you
um
what are some of your favorite machine
learning papers
i would say
okay
i guess it depends if we how we measure
this but
there's one paper
um
that kind of
stands out to me which is quite an old
paper so
um the the creator of what's called
random forests
um this is like a very kind of famous uh
classic machine learning technique um
that's useful for um
especially like tabular data that you
see in industry
and um i had to teach random forests at
university
about a year ago a year and a half ago
and i was like okay i'll read this paper
from the 90s and see if i you know
understand it
and it's it's just a
model of clarity it's like very short
very clearly explains how the algorithm
is implemented and you can basically
just take this paper and implement it in
code very very easily
and that that to me was like a really
nice example of like how papers were
written in the kind of you know medieval
time um whereas nowadays most papers
they have this kind of like formulaic
approach of like okay there's an
introduction there's a table with some
numbers that get you know better and
there's like some you know random
related work section
so so i think you know that's one that
like stands out to me a lot
um but another one that's um a little
bit more recent is um
there's a there's a paper by deepmind
again um on using
um kind of
machine learning techniques to prove
fundamental theorems in
like algebraic topology which is like a
kind of special branch of abstract
mathematics
and
at one point in my life i used to kind
of work on these related topics
and
to me it's like a it's a very exciting
perspective of kind of augmenting
um the knowledge that you know a
mathematician would have
in trying to narrow down the space of
like you know theorems that they might
have to search for
and uh yeah i think
this to me was surprising because
a lot of the time i've been quite
skeptical that like you know machine
learning will
lead to like fundamental scientific um
kind of like insights beyond like you
know the the obvious ones of like just
making predictions but this example
showed that you can actually be quite
creative um and you know help
you know mathematicians
find new new ideas
that is amazing we're going to
definitely link to both those papers in
the show notes of this so people can
check that out
very cool
uh
louis what is the meaning of life
i i think the honest answer is i don't
know and probably anyone who does tell
you it probably is lying but um
but i mean that's that's a bit sarcastic
um
i i don't know i i guess
in some sense like
i kind of
i mean being a kind of
scientist by training and especially a
physicist
you kind of develop this like um world
view that is is very much that like
you know there isn't really some sort of
like deeper meaning to this it's very
much like
you know the universe is is quite random
um
and i suppose
the only thing you can kind of take from
that beyond you know being very sad
is that um
you kind of
you derive your own meaning right and
in most of the time this this kind of
comes either from the work that you do
or from the family or from your friends
that you have
um but i think when you find a kind of
nice way to to sort of derive your own
meaning and find what you do is is
actually interesting and meaningful that
that's like the best
you know part
it doesn't it's i mean life is very up
and down right you don't have this yeah
yeah but um
at least for me personally the the
things that that have always been like
very meaningful are generally creating
things so yeah um
i used to be a musician so that was like
a way of creating
like music for other people and it was
like great pleasure in doing that and
now i kind of i guess create code
it's a form of creativity
absolutely i think that's beautiful
lewis i love that it was a great answer
cool
is there anything else you would like to
share or mention before we sign off
um
maybe
buy my book
yeah
it is so good i
am
it has a parrot on it do you know the
story about this pharah
i don't think so
so so
when when o'reilly um
uh is like telling you you know we're
going to get our illustrator now to
design the cover it's a secret right
like they don't tell you what the logic
is or you know you have no
say in the matter um basically the
illustrator comes up with an idea right
and um
in one of the like last chapters of the
book
we have a section or where we basically
train a kind of gpt-2 like model
um on python code
and this was tom's idea and he
just decided to call it codeparrot um
and i think the idea or the joke he had
was that there's a lot of
kind of discussion in the community
about this paper
um which meg mitchell and others worked
on yes yes you know stochastic parrots
yeah and the idea was that you know you
have these very powerful language models
um which seem to exhibit like human
traits in their writing as we discussed
earlier
but kind of deep down maybe they're just
doing like some sort of like parent
parroting thing you know if you talk to
like a cockatoo
it will you know swear at you or make
jokes and
that may not be like a true measure of
like intelligence right it's like some
sort right
so i think the illustrator somehow
maybe saw that um and decided to put a
parrot which i think is a perfect uh
you know kind of metaphor for
for the for the book and you know the
fact that there are transformers in it i
love that i
had no idea that that was
the way that o'reilly's
covers came about
they don't tell you and they just pull
context from the book and create
something
it seems like it i mean
we don't really know the process but i'm
just sort of guessing that like you know
maybe the illustrator was trying to get
an idea and maybe they i mean i think we
have a few animals in the book like in
one of the chapters we have a discussion
about i think giraffes and
zebras and stuff but
yeah i'm pretty happy that they got a
parrot
i love it well it looks absolutely
amazing congrats once again
highly recommend everyone check this out
it's a great read and it's not as
kind of
i think a lot of
these types of books that at least i've
read and have access to have been quite
dry and technical and this reads almost
a bit like a novel mix with great
applicable technical information which
is
beautiful so well done
thanks yeah i mean one thing we realized
afterwards because like it was the first
time we were writing a book we thought
we should be sort of serious right but
like i mean
if you sort of know me i'm like never
really serious about anything and in
hindsight we should have been even more
silly in the book yeah
you know i
i kind of had to control my my my humor
in various places but still you know i
think maybe there will be a second
edition one day and then we can you know
just inject it with memes
please do please do i look forward to
that
in fact there is one meme in the book
um
and this was this was we tried to sneak
this in past the editor
so
we have the doge
we basically use um
like a special vision transformer to try
and classify what is what this meme is
that's so good
so glad you got that one in there well
done look forward to many more in the
next edition
lewis thank you so much for joining me
today i really really appreciate it and
where can any of our listeners um
find you online or follow you
what platforms are you active on
sure so i'm fairly active on twitter so
you can just find me my handle i guess
is underscore
l-e-w-t-u-n
um i guess linkedin maybe but i don't
know linkedin is a
strange place and i'm not really on
there very much so twitter's your best
bet
um of course there's like plugin face
forums or our discord um you can also
reach me that way
awesome thank you so much
and i'll chat with you soon
thanks a lot brittany bye bye
thank you so much for listening to this
episode of machine learning experts so
louis the best uh
if you or someone you know is interested
in direct access to leading machine
learning experts like lewis who are
ready to help accelerate your ml roadmap
please go to
co support to learn more
and i sincerely hope to see you next
time thanks
you